thank you
[Music]
a man has been arrested shockingly after
opening a heroin cocaine and meth
storage
and this is in Canada it's a good store
though it's a good idea for a story dude
legalize meth and heraway that's all I'm
saying big business yeah what happens if
we Legalize It
never mind then don't they I really want
to know so this is a man who had a dream
make a lot of tax money maybe yeah
but then we get social Decay does it
make it uncool so people don't want to
do it no more that could that would I
think that happened to weed I'll say
that man but don't people do uh opioids
all the time is that the same yeah Jason
writes that yeah so this man had a dream
and a vision and he put on his vision
board this is why you gotta support
small businesses that's right and he
said he's going to open a store called
the drugs store the drug store yeah a
brick and mortar it is not a brick and
mortar oh he was trying to work his way
up but he had to start small so he he it
was out of a mobile home got it I bet he
had cool merch yeah he he says that he
wanted to give people a safe supply of
drugs that have been tested to ensure
they didn't contain Fentanyl and
Vancouver Police say that they found him
drug trafficking in connection with an
illicit drug dispensary that began
operating yesterday in the downtown east
side so they got they got on onto him
pretty quick one day one day police
police said they started father LLC does
it say it in there it does not say oh
man it was an S corp
[Laughter]
you had a Pinterest vision board of all
the drugs that he was going to sell and
he was watching garyvee videos to
motivate him into becoming an
entrepreneur he was doing garage sales
for a while starting small startup is
Biz so police said they started
Gathering evidence after the suspect
started selling cocaine crack
methamphetamine and heroin out of a
Mobile Trailer parked near Maine in
Cordova that's a One-Stop shop who's
this guy's supplier well that was the
dispensary
that they found yesterday oh interesting
connections um so they they basically uh
seized two vehicles some body armor some
Canadian currency
and they say that he is banned that's
what they found uh they say he's banned
from returning to downtown east side as
part of his bail conditions because he's
out on bail and the store had bright
yellow sandwich boards featuring a price
list for all the drugs which range from
ten dollars for a one point which is a
tenth of a gram of meth is that true I
don't know
[Applause]
to two um
to 250 for 2.5 grams of crack is that
true
maybe different street prices
it's Canadian prices oh that's true and
that's why two dollars more that's what
they actually say in this article he
wore a stab proof vest it doesn't say a
bulletproof vest stab proof that's kind
of interesting those are important
because they don't have guns there
right and he sold drugs from behind a
Plexiglas window inside the shop and
said he wanted to stay close to Street
prices and wanted to keep prices as low
as you could for his customers he sounds
like a Robin Hood I I admire the
intention
he's trying to take drugs and money out
of the gangs and into his pocket if
there was a market for him that would be
it right he wants to provide safe drugs
that doesn't have fentanyl to the
marketplace there's definitely a market
for I just don't think it's legal yeah I
don't know anyone that's tried fentanyl
because they always die yeah yeah
it's got to be like one of those secret
restaurants
like a speakeasy yeah a speakeasy book
for drugs
so there's a bit of a turn in this story
he told Vice news that he planned to get
caught oh [__] he goes I wanted to
because I'm like that villain on Batman
that's right yeah because you played
into my tricks now I have you exactly
where I want you and I'm in jail yeah
it's phase two of that oh so phase two I
waited a long time and then I get out of
jail that's exactly it swag watch you
exactly but he's not on bail well so he
says he wants to launch a constitutional
challenge arguing that prohibition has
created a toxic supply of drugs that's
killing Canadians that's not you need to
be arrested yeah
I have no idea but a lot of governments
don't want to get into this business
right because it's just dirty so it's
like I mean there's some Scandinavian
countries that are probably like you
could shoot up here and we'll help
rehabilitate you you know but like I
don't think that shit's gonna work here
no nah probably not
but that's that's kind of it's very
pervasive across our border and Canadian
border right because they are dealing
with fentanyl the same way that we are
yeah and people are you know even like
some prescription medications that are
being sold illegally have been found
with fentanyl wow so yeah it's been
killing University students and stuff
like that I always wonder if like if I
just have an insensitive angle but like
the problem with fentanyl stems from the
problem of the drugs in the first place
so it kind of seems like they're
tackling like a level above when they
should just be like eliminating the
route but then again easier said than
done I'm not addicted to this [__] yeah
right but also it's
a lot of the times the focus is on like
hey
you know [__] these guys for selling
drugs and all this stuff right yeah but
at the end of the day like if they had
no buyers they wouldn't sell it so
how do you deal with the addicts how do
you deal with people to not even get
there in the first place what's
happening with social Decay where people
feel the need to self-medicate so much
so then that's no one's answering that
question but it's always been a war on
drugs and it's like yeah you need to
stop the supply but also if there's no
demand and there's no Supply needed but
don't you think if you just tell kids in
school that drugs are not cool actually
they're not cool it made me more Curious
I think I think it was I think it works
when the guy's saying it is cool yeah
it's never happened or like a guy who's
like a real scumbag and he's like dude
drugs are cool I don't want to hear from
that guy that's a deterrent we gotta
have more of those guys the Dare had bad
casting yeah yeah it really did they
really did sometimes a cop will come in
and you're just like oh it's like God
and it's not even like a cool dirty cop
I think they changed the Dare program
because no longer there anymore and I
think they announced this [__] to DEA
which is hella funny does it really yeah
it's like dead
[Laughter]
let's make it more uniform yeah yeah so
it's like a Jamaican dare yeah
okay
you try to fact Jack yeah
but yeah it is true that like it's just
like the abstinent Outreach like they
brought out people that look like yeah
you guys ever had the um is this going
to be real bad for you yeah yeah you
guys ever had the great program which
which one was that it's like gang
resistance education or whatever we had
we had that and we had dare because
gained recruitment in our elementary
school was happening like from fourth
fifth grade oh wow so then we had this
like former gangster lady can't come in
and her stories like dude she gets PTs
in the middle of her lectures and
superheated right talking about her
Rivals and all this [__] and I think all
the kids at the end of each lecture
would just get riled up from her
speeches yeah and want to join a gang
yeah yeah it was like it started off as
like you don't want this life you don't
want to do this and toward the end it
was like and then we [__] this
crazy and you're just like in third or
fourth grade like damn that's like
that's cool you don't think it's cool to
hear from these guys about drugs
wait there it's a collab dude it's
[__] Ronald McDonald and [__] clue
yeah that's the clue guys the [__]
take a bite out of crime remember that
yeah yeah McGruff
a golden doodle that's what it looks
like who's the dare I think it's
chocolate lab I think he's a chocolate
lab is he yeah who's that girl like that
I don't say that their shirt is pretty
fresh I've never seen him before you
know it was one thing that was effective
was we had the uh the abstinence like
team come to our school and a guy
literally told us that he got uh he got
herpes from getting head in Hawaii
he was just bragging you're bragging
dude but like he was the guy to make
sure to tell us that like hey even if
you're not having all the way sex you
could still get an STD and that actually
did kind of affect us yeah yeah yeah we
were like oh man I thought there was
like a workaround
have you guys ever seen that video of
those guys at like a school and they're
just yelling like virginity is I love
that hold up
opportunity it's cool oh come on it's
like an arm thing they're trying to get
the crowd hiked yeah and they're just on
stage it's cool
yeah it's like the whole straight edge
movement like you're supposed to be
absent no drugs women are distraction
brother you got to keep your eye on the
prize okay men are weak to the flesh
that's what they said that's it baby I
love that stuff man
[Laughter]
do you think he dropped some gems in
there though yeah I think yeah virginity
is cool dude I believe that he's a
virgin yeah
what up
that's my favorite part all the kids
there they're like
yo they are they're like if you don't
believe it they don't believe it yeah
his voice is cracking while he's single
dude it's like the pointer Brothers it's
like that kind of deal
if you guys were a part of that panel
what would you do
it's Cody Cove maybe I wouldn't be able
to like stop laughing that's tough yeah
it's like if we were invited to go help
some kids and all of a sudden that [__]
starts happening I'd be in tears dude I
wouldn't be funny dude [__] I mean it's
weird like to be in the position to tell
kids not to do something is hard because
by the time you're at the age that you
care about telling them they won't
listen to you yeah too old
I also think that they're they're
treating teenagers like toddlers yeah
they're trying to manipulate them with
this like rally it's like just
come on
come on come on come on there's like a
grandpa in the back
like he's like trying to tell them it's
like down middle up yeah that's what
happens when you're not self-aware
unfortunately yeah yeah yeah you can't
tell everyone's like this guy sucks you
think he was riding this and planning it
like all right and at the end we're just
gonna hit him with the virginity is cool
we're gonna roll them up and they're
gonna [__] believe and everybody's
gonna stay a virgin that's why I was
like it's not cool I think like the more
effective thing would be like the the
adverse is uncool like that's easier to
express negative reinforcement tell us
you got freaking blisters all over his
dick from just getting head yeah it's
terrifying like that sucks yeah and then
you show them what uh herpes looks like
you're like oh honestly Google Images is
the best app to this tool let's do it
imagine though instead he's like
blisters on your dick not cool come on
come on
hahaha
that's my favorite part
itching it's a good flooring
foreign